you want to get him up onto the big
right rock in between the left rock so
from the right to the left
and he'll kind of fall off
bro we just need him to go way up here
and wrap into that rock so he'll clip
through the right side of it on this
side left side when we get around it
that's fine
okay and then he stands pretty close
okay this is looking pretty good
may have missed
oh no
oh he's bugging
you see him
he's bugging bro
there it is there it is he got up on it
he got up on it come on come on come on
let's go we actually did it
it worked
but now we have to do it again
oh that's so funny
hopefully this tree is okay it's not
the tree did nothing the tree did
nothing
beep we're doing a we're cheesing this
boss because it's a [ __ ]
[Music]
come on be nice
maybe if i stay right here he'll go
where we want
i don't know where he is
[Music]
he's bugging
oh
what
these balls are opie
what's he doing up there
you'll see
why is he at full health now
there we go there we go
looking better
looking good
this don't [ __ ] kill me
no he thinks he can go around
what an idiot
okay he is aggro as [ __ ] no he's turning
around come back
get over here
get up top
get yes here we go it's gonna happen
please die no
fall off and die you [ __ ]
did it we did it
we actually did
oh my god i can't believe you can do
that i love this game